[Music]
i'm doing an intro to the show with
bryce hall and josh richards we're here
i have a feeling you've heard of them um
okay so we've never met before josh and
i know each other josh and i are friends
you and i are not we're literally
strange i think we're mutuals we follow
each other on instagram yeah we do
that's recent yeah for me when when did
you start following me like after the
roast oh yeah or actually when you were
writing the roast i think oh no oh yeah
because you're posting stories and stuff
like that so here's the thing we worked
i was like i had the best time before
the rose like i i watched it like it was
fine but i feel like they cut all of
that all of her stuff they cut probably
like 70 of my jokes yeah they cut out
not just like they didn't just target me
they cut out a lot of people's jokes i
just watching it was just i'm i'm so
glad i didn't come in person and see you
kill and then see the video after and
it's like dude that's what that's what
all the people that went there though
like yeah and they're like went there
they're glad that they actually saw the
uncensored version because it was way
funnier way better yeah okay i'm going
to send you your set right now
and
if you want to read the jokes that were
cut i think we should i think we should
too and then i can read some of the
jokes that they cut out oh will you
really because also i'm going to read
some of the jokes that got cut uh from
some of my roasts too to make you feel
better all right all right all right if
we're getting cancer
yeah we could all just go down sink this
ship together okay i'm standing here
because it was also it was so
frustrating because like yours were like
thoughtful and the best rose jokes are
the ones that incorporate like current
events and like
you think you're going one way and then
you go this total other way that's like
so surprising and shocking and i think
that like
you're such a like from what i
understand and see and feel from you're
such a fucking good person that you can
go further than anyone right you know
what i mean if you're able to kind of i
think the thing about the ropes is if
you're if you make them thoughtful jokes
that's when you can get away with saying
some crazy stuff i'm not just saying
like you're a fucking slut that's just
your opinion on someone it's not
supposed to be that it's supposed to be
like we're all gonna have this catharsis
and say the craziest possible shit and
like heal
you know like it made me love you
watching that like
as being a roaster so many times and
having it's usually to revive a career
make someone relevant again or to like
baptize somebody and like cleanse them
of their sins right
i felt like i was cleansed after that
100 i mean it's like when justin bieber
did his right totally everyone after
like oh he was a kid that fucked up we
all have been there and he knows and he
has no ego and i fucking love this guy
because he can laugh at himself and he
can like you know
take punches like that that's in the way
that you reacted to it was so fun but
it's also your job is the hardest
because you go up last night and so many
references have been hit already
[Music]
i have a bone to pick with you
you were about to talk about athletic
grains and you removed the diet soda
that was in front of me correct the
whole reason i can drink diet soda is
because i take athletics it's about
balance baby me too i want to drink the
diet
[Laughter]
you're supposed to just put a scoop of
it in uh water every morning yeah and
it's got less than one gram of sugar
it's got no gmos it's got no nasty
chemicals or like anything artificial
and it still tastes good athletic greens
has over seven thousand five star
reviews that's crazy right now it's time
to reclaim your health and arm your
immune system daily nutrition athletic
grades we're heading into the cold and
flu season just don't be a dum-dum
there's no need for a million different
pills that's ridiculous don't be that
person i was that person for so long
where i'd like bend over and just pills
would just drop out of my purse my
pockets i worked for a really famous
movie producer who had
a bit of a pill
issue and she not it's really not
whitney and she we were in the
production office like this was like
years ago in the movie production office
and the
three-hole puncher you know how the
little paper holes come out yeah it had
fallen and spilled everywhere and she
ran over them and started picking them
up because she thought they were her
pills
oh
that's actually it is hard to chill my
bones so just don't play yourself
athletic grades is going to give you a
free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com whitney again it's
athleticgreens.com whitney take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
um okay let's read some of these jokes
because i would you go first they were
so fucking good okay so this one i don't
think you did joke number three
did you number three
uh people clown on jason saying he can't
get work in tv
oh yeah i don't think this one came out
yeah
it was people clown on jason saying he
can't get work in tv wrong
he has a ton of upcoming gigs on to
catch a predator he's in a couple
unreleased epstein documentaries and
chances are in two years you'll see him
on the news storming the capital that
was definitely good
yeah yeah like the jokes it's not like
the jokes didn't hit which surprised me
when they cut it because my brain goes
like okay there was maybe another epson
joke do they cut it because it was that
like it's just such a fucking well
thought out joke yeah dude the ones that
cut out for me like it's kind of
confusing because they weren't even that
bad so like when i was introducing josie
for example i was just like jose
canseco's walking cum is here tonight
it's so short and quick it's so
surprising yeah there it is and it's
also just so sad it gets distilled down
today and then i was like josie josie
actually takes a lot after her father he
ran bases back in his day and she gets
ran through by every man with over a
million followers
like why do you think that the anyone
wrote no i asked josie and i was like
did you tell him to cut this and she was
like no
and josie killed it too so she was she
was awesome yeah so i don't think she
was like oh i'm going to be a weak
roaster and then get roasted type of
thing like yeah i was just like trying
to understand and i think they took out
my anne frank this is the only this is i
think they took out the anne frank okay
let's look because she would be pissed
if she
saw this first we read her diary yeah i
know we read her diary now she's um look
i oh this is one that i did once for uh
hulk hogan that reminds me a little bit
of your joke it was hulk hogan was on
you know he's like was a famous like wwe
wrestler
hulk hogan and uh pam anderson you guys
know very she was also on the days uh
hulk hogan you're uh you're always
wearing so much spandex like i feel like
you have less sperm in your balls and
pam anderson has in her mouth right now
like that's my favorite kind of joke
obviously you don't have sperm in your
mouth right now it's a fucking joke i
mean
it's fossilized yeah it's between your
teeth that was one like uh oh joan
rivers uh joan rivers uh john rivers
vagina is so old it has a separate
entrance for black cocks
i like a history joke i like something
that has a like history to it so it's
like that's i feel like that joke would
not ever happen today because you're
just saying blackhawks yeah right the
one the one that i see that got cut out
because maybe tana asked for this one
remember like the whole n-word scandal
about tana i was like with youtubers and
having said the n-word
i mean don't label don't label all of us
[Laughter]
it's just like you know there's a select
there's something sounds like that was a
very consistent
problem youtube yeah yeah and social
media by the way definitely also a
problem in mainstream television yeah
they just didn't record themselves doing
it right yeah so i was like josie dates
a lot of rappers she does it in hopes of
getting the n-word pass
and loaning it to tana so yeah that was
absolutely such a good joke i know and
then i was like remember tana the hard r
isn't included in the past
because she was like saying it yeah yeah
it was like it was like the would tana
been okay without having stayed in i
mean i said it it's hilarious it was
hilarious the room loved it yeah i mean
that's like the joke we had where it was
like the only thing tana can still get
hard is the r at the end of the end
and that was just like everyone was just
like oh that was that wasn't that your
what's that that one did that one make
it in though no that was not in your set
wow no that was not in your set because
i remember that i remember bryce i
remember looking at you i was saying you
were just like oh my god no like my jaw
just yeah some of his jokes like
literally made me like oh that i cannot
but it's also so well crafted and it's
not like i'm just like trashing you it's
like no and they're like they're like
yeah it's like you're kind of like
calling back to something you said at
the beginning or right so three and then
four i like this one number four is
fucking funny to me
it's it's actually like why would they
cut this adam people are so mean to
jason they compare him to michael
jackson which is not fair
michael jackson had property
and talent
and animals liked him
like it was just like oh man even
animals don't like jason that's so
fucked like it was just like one of
those ones
i think you added michael jackson had
never land ranch jason will never have
land and can't afford an extra side of
ranch
just like the cheesy gun that is
stupid
oh that's awesome because i feel like
you know i'm so pissed
you did such a good job of like doing
super savage one and then kind of silly
one and then savage like that's like the
key to a perfect one the the one that
went the most viral on your set was the
one about my father
that the the little pup
neck is so long is because
it's not even that long it's just like a
muscular thick neck i know
it was the reason your neck is so long
is because you were creating out the
window watching your dad leave yeah yeah
looking for your dad yes
i remember like the react because i
didn't know you were gonna make a joke
like that the genuine reaction from me
and that is hilarious it's just like
oh my god
damn yeah bryce is having like a ptsd
attack on stage it's also picturing you
as a child like what is the
like paints an image and i'm like
watching you as a kid like be abandoned
where are you
um okay five this one got caught jesus
they cut a lot yeah yeah five also we're
successful why are we doing this roast
here
is anne frank's attic too big
oh no no that's right i forgot tana
didn't want that space because it was
too ethnic
but it's a joke because i don't think
she's racist
black people think she's racist
and that one everyone that one was great
too i mean like i don't think she's
racist black people think she's like
and then they cut all my jokes about
josh too oh but this is also great and
then after that uh black people think
she's racist although it's definitely
not helpful that on your merch page you
literally sell white hoodies
all promotions like
yeah josh's joke about my my dad being
gone and they cut out like
this one where i'm like josh recently
started a campaign to stop vaping which
is bullshit
josh sucks more vapes than josie does
rappers dicks
it's also just like it's would that have
gone did they cut all the rapper stuff
um
yeah
weirdly did now that i'm thinking about
it yeah like
even even the tana
um rapper jokes
this is good i like this one uh seven
oh so yeah yeah seven they cut jason as
everyone knows uh trying to be a youtube
star is a middle-aged man and i'm pretty
sure it's public knowledge that he only
found out about youtube because he was
googling can divorced man insert
catheter alone
like it's such a specific and it's
another one yeah that paints that image
so well right like he's just like
craning over his laptop like finger
punching
because you're such a good performer
like there's it's so rare like it's
usually comedians doing it and comedians
can kind of be robotic and we don't want
to like you know try too hard but like
when you were performing these jokes
like you were selling them so well okay
this one is fucking funny as shit anyway
i feel like we could laugh about jason
being broke because we know he's good on
cash ever since david dobrik opened a
college fund for jason's kids oh that is
so sweet that david thought jason's kids
would get into college or survive long
enough to even apply
look it's okay man i heard that fetal
alcohol syndrome can be reversed
and then the transition was awesome too
because it keeps going and goes speaking
of fetal alcohol syndrome
tana mojo's face yeah like here's the
thing you can't just cut shit out with
the way you craft a roast set is
supposed to flow and it just felt so
choppy and such a missed opportunity i
wonder if it was like you guys are so
famous they had to take out your jokes
that they thought would get more
attention because it's you you know what
i'm saying i mean there was
like how they said it to us when we were
there saying like hey we might have to
cut out some of your jokes they were
trying to
paint it as like it's for your
protection right like they were like oh
we don't want you to get canceled but
then but then when we can't go and say
no post them all i'd rather get not i'd
rather get cancelled and people look at
it go like oh these are fucking funny
great jokes this is a roast everyone
knows what we're doing here then come
off like i wasn't funny exactly you know
what i mean i way rather because it's
like you like the transition five ten
years when people go and watch the roast
they're not going to know that jokes
were cut right so then it's like three
years ago people don't watch that roast
it's like they're gonna be like oh these
are oh they're gonna know now
we're on a tour to make sure these are
get heard because it drives me insane
because the worst thing you could do at
a roast is play it safe everyone knows
what they're there for so it's like
ah this drives me insane everyone was
prepared for the worst everyone had like
a few drinks yeah but it's also we
already cut the ones that we're gonna
get you cancelled yeah we already you
already did that i did the editing
already like you don't need to do that
editing for me and it's like all the
roasters after we're all like laughing
with each other and hanging out it's not
like anyone's like no one was like
with someone else no you went too far
it's like
it's a roast also just like it also just
with the flow of the show people were
going so hard at you guys and then for
you to not be able to like retaliate
it's just like frust like like
i i would have had i not known the jokes
you had and listening them now i would
have left him in like god they were so
hard on him and he didn't have a chance
to even retaliate yeah
yep you know okay so let's what about oh
this one 13
they cut
yeah for sure
sorry i know tana is getting a lot of
flack for having a lot of sexual
partners but i think we can all agree
that tana has taken more shots to the
face than alec baldwin's cinematographer
that's
that's the bastion reaction that
everyone had that's the reaction you
want to get yeah it is so hard to shock
people anymore people went under their
tables for that joke because they were
like they were like they were like i
don't want my face to be seen i think in
the crowd laughing after that joke
sounds so crazy a bravery contest
straight up a bravery who has the
biggest balls 100 and it's a form of
respect when you go this hard and go
like that's the reaction you want like
it's it's still going that's what i mean
the reaction's still happening my
favorite that's my favorite reaction
this one this is really annoying that
they cut this one too it's not your uh
uh oh yeah okay this is the tana joke
nobody needs to see photos of you nude
at this point the only thing dana can
get hard is the r at the end of the n
word and then read the next one um
it's not your fault it's not it's just
the surgeries tana it's not healthy to
go under that much anesthesia it
deprives your brain from oxygen but at
this point i think we can all agree that
tana gets less oxygen to her brain than
those kids on the ground at astroworld
oh my god oh that i remember that one
that one was like
yeah just like
i think that was twos maybe like that
one was too soon did did you trample
them yeah so like i was like you do it
you know but it's like there's that is
what the roast is it's like too soon
it's like here i think i think that's
what uh
mike malek was referring to when he went
on the podcast and was like yo they were
astro world jokes yeah yeah like mike
malek went on a podcast something like
dude it was kind of too far like
there's no such thing you go you find
the line you go right over it because
that's what we're doing here okay uh
keep going
my noah joke was
cut completely um i was like no beck's
here tonight noah's despite what
everyone says noah's actually very
comfortable with his sexuality um so
comfortable that he lets men fuck him
see i love the jokes like that dude i
love like these this is almost building
them up as a compliment yeah right like
it's like you're complimenting them at
the start and then and then and then i i
like to point at the two
guys next and i was like curtis markell
you guys know what i'm talking about
yeah yeah like his two friends that are
with them you guys should just
completely take control of this have a
yearly thing you guys do it you put it
on you have to be yearly let's do it
every time whatever everything totally
like with bar store or what i don't know
what version of it but like you guys
should just run it you know like we
don't we don't have like sponsors that
are soft and we can actually say you're
gonna have people begging you to be
roasted i think i'm gonna do this so
only fans approached me about doing
their first tv show like they're gonna
start like a tv network okay and i was
like the only thing i could really do on
there and i was thinking about doing
this during the pandemic of going like
okay it's dirty photos and dirty stuff
i'm gonna do just dirty jokes all the
jokes you can't say on network
television all the jokes that would get
you canceled and i'm gonna start doing a
roast on only fans
because the thing is you can't cancel me
or say i'm offensive if you got onto the
if you know what you're signing up for
and you're paid to watch it yeah you're
paying for that shit exactly i'm not
ambushing you i'm not triggering you
you're hiding it actually as much as you
possibly can exactly right right i'm
saying there's all these like sort of
obstacles to get to it and you're
signing up for it yeah exactly like you
don't go on only fans like what are all
these pussies out like
oh no pussy yeah you know what you're
signing up for so like i wanted to do it
and they like love that idea and it's
all the shit you can't say anywhere else
i think that's a wicked and you can't
just like pick it up and put it on
youtube or whatever because it was like
that might be the only version of being
able to do roasts like for real yeah i
thought this was gonna i was like i
thought this was finally gonna break so
did the culture in like social media a
little bit and like give us that room to
make crazy jokes because the only people
that are going to be able to break that
standard are the people in social media
right now we all just agree like hey we
all don't give a fuck and we're not
going to play this game where we're
scared and we're not worried about you
guys suing us are we triggering you or
having kid gloves with you like and i
felt like it was about to be that
yeah
it wasn't me
yeah because it's like it's the perfect
guy to be roasting because i've been
canceled maybe fucking uh
it made me like love you hey thanks it
was like so fun to like watch you be
able to just like take it it was like so
endearing i don't know i just i'm like
i'm gonna stop talking about how
annoying it was and honestly the most
fucked up jokes get the most the best
reactions
yeah yeah so people people will try to
cancel you for it but it's like you
still definitely watch it and you were
definitely like oh yeah that's the
reaction we wanted yeah that's exactly
the direction we want and we i'm not
going to say that in under any other
circumstances except here on this roast
yeah uh this one
uh
oh the logan paul one i fucking loved
josie you dated brody jenner g-eazy and
logan paul can someone please give josie
conseco covet so that she loses her
taste in men and then they took out the
next yeah yeah josie josie is famous for
dating logan paul i wish you guys would
have gotten married i hear the suicide
forest is beautiful this time of year oh
okay yeah that's why that got cut yeah
why
it's hilarious logan would have loved it
i don't know i feel like he jokes about
it on his of course he does of course he
does he doesn't joke about it dude looks
like he's seen the clip when like 24k
golden was on he was like oh have you
ever been to japan and then logan's like
okay and he's like looking at the camera
chain he's like making it like he's like
yeah i have a feeling like
logan's not worried about bad attention
i feel like he would have been fine i
think he's already kind of like proven
he is sorry about that and like has his
already had his redemption but then
there was a little thing
of if like if people didn't get it or
didn't know i wish you guys got married
i hear the suicide force is beautiful
this time of year and if you didn't get
that joke because of the steroids your
dad took when he got your mom pregnant
i'm trying to say you guys should kill
yourself
so that's the part i didn't say even at
the real rose that's the only one
actually i think when i was looking
through the
the list and i was like
telling a girl to kill herself maybe i
can't do that one maybe i can but was it
do you but did it hit hard enough oh
yeah that's when it hit where everyone
was like oh my god right so it's like
okay i was like
that was like if they didn't if it did
like if she didn't get it or everything
like that
if people forgot about it i personally
made a joke about josie um i said
josie's one of the dumbest people i know
the perfect example as to why you
shouldn't have a kid while taking
steroids so that's funny that that you
said that too yeah yeah
what is that oh so 25
is
so good
dude
well this is about uh this is about jeff
whitaker yeah yeah
jeff what is going on with your face man
you look like what would have happened
if bella hadid had landed that punch on
zayn malik
and then after that it was like
i mean you look like the twin theo
vaughn ate in the womb
that's fine what did you tell your
surgeon you were going for rebel wilson
and cats
why would you cut that i know i mean i
feel like i feel like tick-tock kids
probably wouldn't get the cat's
reference maybe so like maybe if they
were going for that it was like it came
out like two years ago and it was like a
massive like failure yeah but like those
are some look showgirls was like a is
now like a cult classic that was thought
of as like the worst movie ever made but
now it's like
kind of the best right
if something is the worst at one point
it's the best later yeah yeah
you're saying take an edible and watch
cats it'll change your life
they animated
taylor swift they're all james corden
they're all cat humans
and they realized after they had
released the movie that a lot of them uh
they forgot to cgi buttholes on the cats
so they re-released it with buttholes
like it's
wild yeah super weird can you have you
seen the trailer i've never even heard
of it here's the thing that was fucking
with me the most when we were working on
roadstrokes is like references are so
important and i was like i just want to
make sure everyone in the room gets the
same reference but why don't you know
about cats i've never heard of it
the musical or the movie no
he didn't know it was a musical leader
just said yeah i was like wait that's
right wait do you what what is that what
is that i'm also very like disconnected
yeah very disconnected you would be so
surprised how this is obviously one of
the like you know i'm a very talked
about guy but i have i don't watch
anything he just knows what's going on
in social media like he knows everything
that's going on on social media like
more than i do but if i ask this guy to
name like three players on a sports team
like that just won the super bowl he'd
be like
oh yeah well but dude it's just not
possible like on twitter like you don't
follow like news on twitter like where
do you get your news i don't okay
by the way a good uh that's why you're
in such a good mood
now would not be the time to start
reading start reading the news
we are at war okay we're taking a break
i like to like
think about what someone's inner
monologue is while they're listening i
think i made the grave mistake of
reading some of bobby lee's comments oh
and i
i've been i'm quit no i'm quitting no no
no i'm not quitting or i need
a diet smoke oh yes
i'm going to need a diet smoking i
thought that i couldn't do edibles
because i was doing the wrong ones they
had too many drugs in them and i stand
by that's why i was so crazy during the
pandemics
that's why because i was high when
you're trying a bunch of like random
edibles they all hit you different and
which is why diet smoke is perfect right
because it's organic it's all natural
i'm just psyched that i can do edibles
again yeah but i only am doing this one
because it's more than cbd uh also yeah
bong rips is too much also i don't want
my house smelling like smoke like this
isn't a frat house this is not a frat i
don't want to be rolling joints and
having roaches everywhere listen to
sublime yeah i don't want to i
have no
um uh sorry not everyone only listens to
reba
enjoy the smooth relaxing high of diet
smoke right now diet smoke is offering
our listeners an incredible discount
when you go to diet smoke.com use the
promo code you can just buy weed gummies
online that's crazy yeah that's yeah
this is so wild you'll get 20 off of
their uh delta eight thc gummy uh
dietsmoke.com promo code whitney get 20
off that's diet smoke.com promo code
whitney for 20 off when the diet smoke
gummies get stuck in your teeth
cocoa floss is the jam hold on i
actually have one of my purse now okay
cocoa floss i'm obsessed with this
dental floss so i i because can i tell
you in my day you would roll up the
dental floss oh yeah it would like cut
into your fingers you got the
circulation off the tips of your that's
how villanelle kills people and killing
eve yeah with just like a that's how
people like break out a prison with
floss it's wild it's the easiest way to
um cut a cake it's sharper than a knife
why are my gums always bleeding i do do
this every day and then i started using
the little plastic ones the one used
ones and those are so bad for the
environment right like you're such an
asshole if you do that so then i kind of
just gave up my faucet
and my doctor was like uh dum dum and
then coco floss exists now look how cute
this is look at how cute i know can i
tell you it was invented by just two
sisters one is a dentist and one is an
artist so they made it
the proof is in the pokemon baby it's
not great it's hilarious yeah i call it
my coco chanel floss okay
there's a pina colada one this is cara
cara orange yeah the orange is really
good but there's a strawberry plastic
mint is really good the strawberries i
mean they're all they're all like and
they're non-toxic they're eco-friendly
there are no parabens uh free of sls and
pfas and each spool is made from
recycled water bottles which is awesome
yeah that is wild avoid mask breath by
flossing look at this no blood
i'm flossing live on the show right now
and she's not turning into the joker no
blood because i've been using coco floss
yeah and you can too if you just go to
cocoa floss dot me slash whitney to get
twenty percent off the four spool set
and free shipping
c o c o f l o s s dot m e slash whitney
and the discount will automatically be
applied at checkout still no blood and
all orders over 20 ship for free in the
u.s
look quit flossing and tell us where we
can see alive no blood still but there
will be blood this weekend april 1st
austin texas paramount theater april 2nd
dallas texas
this is the kind of shit i do it's like
silence of the land with my dude
and i guess he's trying to fall asleep
and i'll be like
would you love me if i look like this i
thought we were and i get in trouble for
hammering up for the camera what if i
look like this whitney is using a piece
of dental floss to make her nose into an
oinker little pink wait look at whitney
compared to this big binder
oh life imitating oh you know what you
look like you look like a who
yeah i love who's
cindy you
i don't know this is what people with
childhoods talk about i don't even know
what that means like what are you saying
uh april 2nd i'm going to be in dallas
texas at the majestic theater april 3rd
san antonio i'll be at the tobin center
of the performing arts april 9th uh new
orleans louisiana april 22nd portland
oregon arlene schnitzer concert hall may
20th i'm in tyson's corner june 26th
toronto danforth music hall i'm a
musician now i'm not doing comedy see
this i like ah fuck 27 is so good yeah i
don't want to be too harsh on tana and
josie i mean they're gorgeous funny
smart i'm sure i'd want to date them if
it wasn't for the self tanner thing it
just it freaks me out i just worry if i
went down on them then got photographed
that i'd be canceled for going in
blackface
and that's my prime minister's job
i mean
like it's come on but you're saying i
don't want to be in blackface because
that's wrong exactly i don't support
this shop self-tanning and i'm gonna
call out the motherfucker that did do it
for real uh like that's always been
insane okay i love that yeah speaking of
men and too much makeup adam w is here
it's such a good job it was awesome it's
such a good sense this guy is so like
well-groomed it's wild he's his face
looks like a
pound cake yeah like it looks like he
puts on contour for it okay
which is so funny okay and then which
one okay so adam uh is uh like it like
he does stand up i think a little bit
like does a creator does videos but he's
not really like
friends with you guys right he's not in
like this and me and bryce's world of
social media he's more in like the
generation the generation before us kind
of like vine era where it's like a
little bit more like kitty videos yeah i
would say but um yeah i mean they they
took out my entire set on adam so it was
like i started off by saying i was like
i don't know that much about you adam
i'm sorry
um
no no wait i do i do know you i have
seen your videos come up at like 3am on
my feed
even instagram knows that no one should
be consuming your content when they're
sober
and then it was like i do like your
content though i'm impressed by your
activism and charity
all that charitable work you do is is
absolutely amazing i i truly think it is
so cool that you make content
specifically for kids with down syndrome
oh i remember that you give
that's such a fun to sincerely right
because it's like i'm i'm being like
you're amazing doing it perfectly you
know what i'm saying like the way you're
delivering it it's just the idea of like
dude it is so cool that you do that yeah
it's like
that's so funny just like you do this
for you guys can't say retard right
that that's definitely like not a lot
that's definitely that's the word that's
definitely like
dude even even when i was in like middle
school they were like spread the word
end a word
really yeah that was like like a trend
thing yeah yeah well they're not in my
town that did not reach my town it must
be an american thing dude when we were
kids we would be like
i mean we were literally like the shit
oh no yes it's like you weren't like
told that was like a bad thing to be
doing yeah yeah yeah
six years old the shit we did like the
stuff that should actually go away you
know like i'm all for like when i think
about the stuff that we did when we were
like in high school the shit that we
would talk like i am so fucking glad i
did not have social well i guess i mean
yeah i was thank god i was on social
media high school yeah every video with
me being like third the third like i
mean it's back okay well now there's one
yeah well yeah there's actually like
three you've done like four you've
really double grounded this i will i
will not fucking be scared like if you
i'm explaining a word you can't say
you're gonna say it yes and then you
mimic it how am i gonna learn if i don't
make the mistake yeah so imagine us when
we're we're doing all those mistakes and
when we're like
yeah there's just millions of people
watching and criticizing like how do you
know what to apologize for what do i
think we're pretty good i i think what
do you realize what's wrong now um we we
definitely
like border the line a little bit yeah
with some of the shit that we do but
everything that we do that gets like a
lot of attention it's it's not enough to
cancel us but not like
when do you self-censor and when do you
not when are you like oh we should cut
that like what's oh we said all the time
in our videos we're like just cut that
out yeah just cut it it's just like how
we it's it's like usually we have a
couple people in the room as well when
we film so we kind of
see what the vibe is in the room right
are people like laughing at that joke is
that cool or was there a lot more like
yeah it was probably a weird nervous
laughter but i don't know i just feel
like such a big part i mean to me just
again as a roast joke person where i'm
like it's all about bravery and all
about like if you're gonna ask for
someone's time you better show them
something that they can't see anywhere
else that was the craziest time that was
like the first time uh an influencer got
that much press like mainstream prize
mainstream press because you guys are
now like just jared and all those
tabloid sites like you guys are now like
that yeah yeah i think which is why
during like the pandemic is when we
started the first time a tick tocker
went mainstream was when me and jaden
got arrested
probably what did you get arrested for
yeah it was in texas yeah texas oh god
yeah yeah um that's but our mug shots
went like supervisor it was pretty cool
like do you when are you like uh i wish
i hadn't done that or now you're just
like you know what i mean i'm a human
being i'm growing up in public it's just
part of the i mean like in the moment in
the moment you're like damn that sucks
we probably just shouldn't have brought
it right but i think like now but i'm
not like
i smoke weed i smoke weed publicly yeah
it's not like league sleepover yeah yeah
it's like i'm just so curious like what
like you know what to acknowledge and
what not to acknowledge because you're
just going to make it bigger if you were
like how do you know when something is
big versus feels big we haven't done
something that's like
i feel like our answer a lot of the time
since that wrestling was always just to
joke around about it i think
right but when we had his 21st birthday
party in like kind of the middle of
covid um that's when everyone was like
and that was like right after like the
mayor had pretty much like we were
already kind of like put out as like
these poster boys of like coven partying
and like don't party during the pandemic
like these guys yeah um you know like
the the nasty oh because you guys like
distancing or something yeah we were
having like 400 people over at the house
for a party and it was like encoded so
yeah probably not smartest thing to do
but 21st birthday you only have that
once so yeah he goes and throw we throw
his 21st birthday the mayor had already
put out this release saying like if
these continue we're gonna shut off your
water and power i don't know if you
remember when that was a thing yeah but
he was like we're gonna shut off your
water and power and then like fine bitch
i got my annie
baby showering yeah energy and liquid
come on i know that people that are
stoned don't give a fuck yeah we've got
insets and candles like we threw the
party and then they because they said
that they were gonna shut off our power
and water they didn't that next morning
and the response was literally like oh
look at us enjoying our hot shower right
now like those were the videos like
we were
and then it got like national coverage
yeah and then they shut off yeah and
then they shut off the power the mayor
the mayor was actually like beefing with
me on twitter yeah and he was just going
back and forth and honestly i was i look
was meme in it like i was being like a
21 year old douchebag like i was posting
pictures and masks and i was like i was
like
we
pandemic movie night with the boys and
we're like all there just being like
i mean i guess it's like again like i
just i just defend that because it's
like fine if the mayor is like this is
the obvious thing to just like look at
the silly monkey just distract from the
fact that like you guys don't have your
fucking vaccines in order you're not
paying your nurses there's everything's
under staff like you're just you're
putting the focus on you guys
in order for us to avoid all the ways
that you were not prepared for this and
have failed and then after he like
completely was trying to trash us like a
week later he was seen out of dinner
with like 30 people or something like
that and it was just like it was just
like that
man they used us as uh the example i
knew so too yeah it was definitely just
like oh here the you know look at how
much attention this is getting i'm gonna
be the mayor and tweet at them now yeah
just don't do this shit but what are
your what what are your brace ones that
got cut sorry i'm jumping around no it's
okay uh i like you know what i couldn't
tell if people knew this uh uh like how
did this one do in the room anyway bryce
is from baltimore i think it's so cool
that bryce stays true to his hometown by
always having crabs i don't think people
really got that because did you get it
you got it because you got it yeah this
is fucking this is savage i get why they
cut it but they still should have left
it out should have left bryce isn't gay
in fact he gets with lots of girls yeah
that one was awesome no bryce isn't gay
in fact he gets with a lot of girls
bryce you've smashed more la pussy than
a bike seat at soul cycle and you've
eaten more la pussy than jojo siwa
that one was awesome is jojo
that did that kill in the room oh yeah
people were like jojo siwa they were
like what the fuck where did that come
from that's like not true i'm talking
about like the smashing more pussies and
like uh
you
you're saying you don't get pussy no i'm
not saying that i'm just saying i
haven't smashed more
right there's a lot going through no you
smash girls foreheads with that fucking
necklace as they have to get it hit
i know if you fucked a girl because it
has pau backwards just like an in-depth
i'm gonna wrap up so i can go talk to my
publicist about which girl up here i
need to issue a public apology to yeah i
love that because you're just
acknowledging my my ending was so so
smooth too it was like the
all right i'm gonna go get drunk in the
back probably go to an after party um
josie i'll see you at 2am tana 204. yeah
i think that was like one of my favorite
jokes you had in the entire night it
just it hit so well too because i wasn't
expecting another joke yeah i thought
like how he was doing it it really was
like he was wrapping up like all right
thank you everyone for being here and
then i was just like boom one more slide
i'm surprised nobody bombed at the roast
well like
i don't know how to say it but like some
people like like nobody like everybody
brought it everybody everybody like kind
of and that's what i was like worried
about i was like either
everyone's gonna not take it seriously
and it just be like sloppy stories and
then you're gonna seem like a real
fucking bully coming in with such sharp
like articulate jokes but everyone
everyone brought yeah
everyone brought it and kind of like
well that's the one thing that i i love
like the more
uh people i hang out with they're like
creators that came up on youtube you
guys know yourselves very well like
you're not delusional about how you're
perceived and that's kind of different
with like athletes some comedians and
actors
like you guys know more self-aware yeah
right which i kind of would the
stereotype might be like the opposite
stops complete
complete opposite i think people think
that tick tockers
i mean i guess like i i think people i
mean you know what's funny about you oh
yeah right and i know like we know what
to make fun of about ourselves don't be
aware how many people hate me out there
it's not hate i think it's just you've
signed up to well
no the mo i'm a female comedian there's
no no more hated species than a woman
that just fucking church and like
attacks man and you don't get to fuck
her at the end like it's just like
everyone's nightmare i've gotten so much
public hate like
rough like really i was like the first
person that was canceled basically
really yeah like but i had a tv show on
nbc and i just got it got so much press
and it was like it was very it was
brutal yeah no at one point it was bad
for me like got to the point this is
when you know it's bad i would like i
was working so much i was doing two two
i was doing two broke girls on uh cbs
and the whitney sitcom simultaneously
and the talk show for e and so i didn't
have time like you i wasn't watching two
broke girls yeah i created it oh
that's sick okay i've watched that right
thank you
i gave you some money there
thank you
uh whenever you get around to googling
me taking another break to talk to you
about rothy's you guys i don't know if
you're when you follow me on instagram
and i'm in the airport i'm always
wearing rothy's i have you know what
angelina jolie wears these yeah have you
ever seen somebody sprint through the
airport in flat
they're weirdly they have like a grip on
the body it's incredible look this is
the only reason that i don't check
luggage is because you can also bend
them like this like these flats you can
keep them in your purse you can put it
in your luggage yeah yeah like sticking
in a diva cup but for your feet
that's perfect very comfortable sticking
in i would have said jamming or thumbing
it shoving shoving it
a diva cup
people magazine named uh this this shoe
the best flat for their first ever style
awards in 2021 so
don't take it from me every every time i
wear these people ask me about it yeah
and they also make
sneakers loafers and ankles the sneakers
are so comfortable sneakers yeah but i
have these in black i have actually the
leopard one is my favorite they're so
cute i love the one with a bow on it
that's my i feel like jackie kennedy i
love it i also uh
we were in a fitting yesterday and i've
come to terms with the fact that i
have a genetic gift it has been passed
on to me it is called hammer toe
uh my hammer toe is coming in my mom
always had congratulations a giant
hammer toe on the side here and she was
always like i hope you don't get this i
hope you don't get this mine came about
40. and uh i feel it like coming like in
a couple years and it doesn't hurt
because flats are too narrow for me i
have haglon's deformity which is where
the back of my heel is like protruding
these are like one of the only pairs of
shoes that i can wear don't laugh it's a
it's a
you can get both style and comfort this
spring with rockies plus get 20 off your
first purchase at rothys.com whitney
that was
r-o-t-h-y-s dot com slash whitney i like
to put my feet up in my rothys after a
long hard day on my extreme what have
you had a hard day recently extremely
comfortable article furniture but hold
on you're going to pick with you oh do
you think that my job is like no i knew
you were gonna do this i knew this
because i said the other day i
exaggerated i know exactly where this is
coming from you were like doing
something you're like i work all the
time i was like this would be like three
hours a day or something
love it i always am working i know i
know i know yeah and when i'm not
working i'm thinking of you
well then it's not that it's foreign
this is my love this is my passion i
don't have a relationship i'm losing
friends i'm one don't have a baby no no
i just love i'm away i love work i'm one
no you're not you don't love work if you
love work you would have given yourself
a wedgie for 7 500 right now no i love
this work i don't love work in general
i don't live anywhere
so i shouldn't pay you
because it's not a job
you love it yeah this is
there should be a non-profit
you are a special guest
okay aren't you going to move soon i am
emily i am and i'm going to departments
last week that's crazy why
you've lived in your place for so long
that's so exciting for eight years yeah
yeah i think you need to totally do not
bring furniture do not bring the
furniture keep tracking all of it okay
good well then you shit on something
[Laughter]
and if you cut this out i'm going to
bring it up on the live channel
yes i shot myself on my ikea couch
because you know what that's what i
think about ikea yeah
no because i haven't gotten my article
furniture yet which i would never shit
on um
i yeah i've been having fun but even if
you do the outdoor furniture it is water
uh i was just looking this up because
i'm getting article outdoor furniture it
is treated and waterproof so you can
just hose it off should you should i
shit incident should you get drunk and
think it's ikea for a second right but i
wasn't drunk because i was i was
watching tv in the middle of the evening
see i feel like you
are making it worse for yourself now
like you could have just been like i was
drunk i know what happened shoot you
know what i was you're like i know
that's i mean no you know what maybe you
know it's an illness not a i just don't
understand if like did you not have any
warning what you really would be upset
about is if you saw how close my couch
was to my bathroom it's like this but
did you did it it was like bridesmaids
moment where you're like no that was in
the parking garage after we had yes
confused yeah yep that did this was that
wasn't i'm ill no wait i do i've shit
myself like twice in the past six months
you guys i i feel like i am the biggest
beastly pig there is and i've never shit
myself like even when i was a baby i
didn't listen
i like what are you okay like what's
happening
but you have no warning like it just
sometimes though but then doesn't it is
it's well no but doesn't it hold on i'm
just sorry
doesn't your underwear doesn't your
thong stop it though or your pants why i
wear full butt underwear catch it but
just
but how does it not like
just go back in your butt like a prairie
like prairie dog yeah why doesn't your
anus pinch it keep it in your butt
i you tell me i don't know i have a very
intact anus it just it
your butt is not stopping the poop from
coming in for some reason sometimes you
just lose the ability to clench
you need to start eating gluten
i feel like whatever you're doing i need
to do kegels for my asshole oh that's
what i need i don't know what is go i
just i don't understand
i'm confused i wish i could tell you i
wish i could tell you too i i i i've
been this way my whole life one time i
shot myself in stretch pants do you know
what that's oh god see this is recent
for me
it's been my whole life
i shot myself on a date once walking
around new york city shot myself on a
date i was wearing a minnie's dress a
white mini dress with a gold
collar
a gold collar that feels like a kate
spade finally his basement
but it wasn't from filing's basement
anyway article look whether you're
pooping on your furniture whether you
can hold your shit and whether you can't
article will be there for you they have
beautifully crafted pieces so you will
be so inspired by their beauty that you
will hold in your feces quality
materials durable construction
can i test some articles like
article.com is like my porn i just like
we'll send gray screen grabs yeah and
i'm like can we get three in the morning
i'm like can we get that so let's get
this wait don't buy that one yet i think
i want this one like i'm obsessed the
wicker outdoor furniture is so gorgeous
it is so cute and i got from them i had
four navy outdoor chairs two rocking
chairs and two like ones that are really
low to the ground that you can like
perfectly just put like drinks and
coffee on i moved those and i made
little uh we call them in the decor game
moments
so i've created a couple little moments
where i've gotten these little article
outdoor side tables with my like farm
chic uh moment and then my little
scandinavian moment and then i'm about
to do my wicker moments i'm getting four
of the big outdoor wicker chairs what a
story i know and i'm gonna put it around
a outdoor fireplace
because like
if i've learned anything about living in
california is that like having fires
outside is just such a good idea yeah
everybody loves it when you do that all
your neighbors do yeah
and now articles offering our listeners
50 off your first purchase of 100 or
more go to article.com whitney and the
discount will be automatically applied
at checkout it's that easy that's
article.com whitney to get 50 off your
first purchase of 100 or more
oh guess what
i'm ready to retire therefore we are
going to do our first live podcast where
we're just going to be bat shit crazy
shit ourselves
by the way now that i know you guys are
still shitting yourselves like i doing a
live show might be a big
it might be a shit show
you're so proud of yourself like
that
like if i just love that the when you do
and don't have shame is just fascinating
to me because the idea of like making a
fun like shit show
i'd be like sorry well i hate myself
you're just like no
i'm standing by that
relentless eye contact
still love it still love it not backing
down easter sunday the 17th so a lot of
people are doing uh live podcasts i
wanted to wait and sort of just like
figure out exactly because i just i
don't want to be boring if you're tuning
in live and like buying tickets to a
live podcast it's at momenthouse.com i
know it has to be bananas so we are
doing
uh truth or da strip strip tr strip
truth
truth or dare
we don't know the truths or the dares
that we're gonna ask each other i'm so
scared i
i'm like this is the area i'm in just so
you know how insane this live show is
gonna be i'm not gonna
i was gonna do emily i dare you to cut
off an inch of your hair never am i
allowed to do
i dare you to cut off and injure your
hair or take
a mush
this magic mushroom i'll cut off an inch
it could be an either or like you have
to do one of the other you have to do
one yeah you have to yeah but a truth or
dare so no this should be like high risk
it's going to be very highest date yes
this will be a very high stakes and then
we're going to do never have i ever yes
for christchurch is going to join us
i forgot about dares for burns oh my god
i feel like he'll do anything i have oh
my god i feel like uh oh i know i i
didn't even think of that yet okay i'm
gonna think of those it's a live digital
experience go to momenthouse.com good
for you get your tickets it's gonna be
amazing oh
i'm scared
oh my god i just realized i should let
my nipple grow hair out oh nipple hair
grow out you got so excited you got your
face i got so excited that i flubbed
that yeah
because like i dare you to plug one of
my nipple hairs with your teeth with
bert we should do that perfectly yeah
i dare you to plug one of my nipples i
might need to dare bert to give me a job
after i get myself inspired from this
one remember the new york times had the
hit out for us
yeah yeah when sway was first blowing up
like the new york times people wanted to
like cancel us interview us they would
interview our neighbors trying to be
like how bad are these kids as neighbors
like all that stuff oh my god yeah it
was bad that's so wild well it's because
like they're they sell less newspapers
than like your photos get liked
i don't even know do you ever take stuff
down
don't tell me what but are you ever like
i feel like i should take that down or
isn't it you have to keep stuff up
because then if you start taking stuff
down people start going like i feel like
it looks worse if you delete something
after you've posted it if i i don't
think i've ever taken anything down i
don't do a lot of posts and deletes
unless like
one time i deleted something because
like i uploaded an entire raw youtube
video that i accidentally didn't edit
whatsoever so i put in the whole file
like it was a 28 minute file i uploaded
to youtube with no
roommate comes upstairs he's like
pointing at his phone and like smiling
laughing kind of but like an awkward
laugh and i was like ha ha yeah i got
you because like we said some jokes
about it i'm on it and i was like ah
yeah yeah and so i go and check my phone
on like the drama site right where they
would post everything and i'm scrolling
through i'm like god damn 12 of their
recent poster all about my tea talk
video there's different clips i clicked
one and i was like
yeah no that video was not in my mind
because we were so sorry it was just
like fucked up shit yeah we were just
making like boys like truly joking when
we feel like no camera's gonna be on
making fun of a roommate it was how long
was it up
like probably hours three hours have you
guys read this book uh so you've been
publicly shamed
no no it's so
i knew the answer to that yeah
come on stop reading books so books um
uh it is john ronson wrote it it's about
online shaming and it's historical
antecedents how this has always happened
throughout history always always always
like you know the roman coliseum and
like public hangings and stuff like that
and our like biological basis our
propensity to need to publicly shame
people and like glom on oh like when we
used to like throw stones at people yeah
literally and like witches burn witches
shit like that like we get like we are
wired for that mob mentality and it's
not even like personal it has nothing to
do with you it's just like oh we're
mobbing this person great oh we're
robbing this person and i honestly think
that like for all the people that get
cancelled for stuff like this that are
just like honest mistakes or like i just
didn't know i really think it makes
people like you more and go like i've
done that we've all fucking done shit
like that
yeah well it definitely makes the people
like
i think everyone likes a redemption
story yeah like everyone loves a
comeback story and also the people that
will stick by you through that are going
to be so die hard like it's
you're never losing those fans or those
people that like support what you do for
the life um okay are there any more
jokes that you did not get to tell
because i wanted together those were
like the ones that were just kind of
there did any of them kind of hurt
uh towards me yeah no
is there anything that really could hurt
your feelings when i was fat when i was
fat people would make fun of my my
weight and that like i was bullied all
throughout my school years with that so
even like when i'm
kind of out of the gym and stuff and
someone's like oh you're not looking too
good it's like oh fuck mine just look
complete like pretty much opposite where
it's just always been made fun of for
being really skinny right so it's really
traumatic so it's like growing up like
it's like and it's like i know people
will say it and they don't think it
heard they're like oh i want to be
skinny you're so lucky right like they
think it's like that like girls want to
be smaller boys
like i remember like grade 8 and i was
like i'm like i'm like oh so defeating
bro i was like flirting with a girl and
she's like your legs are so skinny like
i wish i had your legs and i was like oh
my god bro i can't stand
and this is something that i think as we
were like talking about rose jokes is
like you never go after something that
that someone can't change about
themselves you know what i mean you go
after their choices not like their fixed
looks you know because that's just like
that's the most fucked up separate i
mean yes except for you're like but it
seems like that's a choice
no i said your neck dude where did you
get curved dick i thought you said your
dick
not even close all right you just set
yourself up man sounds like you just
want to talk about your terms you just
have a problem with talking about your
own kids sounds like you said dick what
is wrong with a curved dick i feel like
that would feel so much better that's
right boring-ass
josie wants to make all those jokes
about it that was but that's the whole
thing about getting the g-spot is that
all the good but it's not a curse
to the right it's curved to the right
left oh is it yeah but but if you have
sex if you're uh it's like he has to
parallel we gotta yeah we just gotta do
like to go in like if we make a plus
sign with our bodies it'll scoop up
perfectly and that's how sex toys are
all designed because that's where the
g-spot is yeah that's true
[Laughter]
let me ask you just last thing about um
i feel like it's like the new anxieties
that you guys have like i feel like
like older generations are like
you guys have depression and anxiety and
all this stuff like every older
generation is going to dismiss the very
real anxieties and fears and like
self-conscious shit of them like you
didn't go through it
exactly but like the ones that i hear
about you guys i feel like are so unfair
and uh and what like you talking about
like body insecurities i feel like
there's there's this narrative that's
like toxic masculinity and boys now are
like toxic because they grew up on like
crazy porn but also if i may i was
trying to make an argument earlier with
grace is there anything to this because
all of the guys that i'm meeting that is
like your guys's age are i'm not trying
to like say your pussies but you're so
kind and nice is that okay to say like
what do you mean like we're just not
degrading no yeah that's what i'm saying
and everyone's uh narrative is they
watch all this porn they objectify women
my argument would be the opposite
because you grew up on porn you went
that's the object i'm gonna objectify
the person objectifying themselves and
now women are human beings that aren't
on the screen that i'm jerking off to
and like i think this is the argument
i'm gonna make that because you guys
you're it used to be before porn guys
only opportunity to see a naked woman
was if they
got to fuck the naked woman or got the
woman naked so everybody hustlers yeah
there was always like a way exactly or
strip club it was always like women were
this um a point of frustration because
the only way i can get my needs met is
to get you naked but now it's like
you can see women naked so often that
now just women in the world don't have
to all be so objectified does that make
sense yeah yeah no it definitely matters
it definitely makes sense it's like
probably also like how my mom raised me
a little bit personally same i had a
single mother so i mean like i've never
been like a i just think porn is like an
outlet it's like you're gonna have to
get your sexual frustration out whether
it's porn or a human and before
definitely healthy to watch porn and
jerk off like it's like then you don't
have that that
you're not
or if you're really creative you can
just like look at pictures
oh you're talking about like imagination
yeah imagination type shit yeah i don't
even watch porn spanx
well it's just like you know if you have
like a great butter when you just start
like
i i don't watch
your head like porn
all the time i probably say like i watch
porn maybe once
once a week
why'd you smile at me i drew it
that's definitely not that much in in
this world of like guys jerking off it's
definitely more like seven times a week
for most guys probably more like seven
times a day yeah yeah but i'm just
saying there's so many people because
you guys are like
i jerk off
like three three four times a day i just
feel like you guys can make friends with
girls like truly platonic friends
am i right that means
that's new that's like not like i don't
know i just think that like there's
always a stereotype that the younger
generation like punks that like
everyone's like obsessed with how fucked
up you guys are and i feel like you're a
delight thank you thank you so much and
i don't like i understand that because
it's true yeah
stupid
i mean you should read more books
in general and you should probably read
the news like at some point
maybe like check it out um uh we're
about to go into like a global i mean i
know i know about that yeah you've seen
it on a stick talk for you page but
you're good you move to vegas and no one
wants no one's going to be they're
bombing that place
you're going to be fine they're going to
be their party
let's not fuck with them they're already
miserable enough okay i'm doing a couple
more rows jokes and then we're leaving
robin quivers robin quivers she's see
this is something you could never
fucking say today she's howard stern
sidekick she's black and she dated a lot
of like white guys that was kind of like
the thing robin quivers fucked so many
white guys abercrombie and fitch took
out ad space on her taint
i feel like
that's that is that's a pretty great
joke
i don't think you'd be able to do that
now yeah i don't know i think it's just
important to say these and why they
don't hold up anymore and like and
comedy's fashion anything we're saying
right now that's hilarious in 10 years
yeah exactly you look back at clothes
and you're like oh what the fuck
sometimes yeah the way you look at your
haircuts or whatever but you have to be
able to go oh this is like a time
capsule the joke that doesn't work
anymore and then lisa lampanelli
was white comedian and she would only
fuck black guys uh was the joke on her
lisa your vagina is like a bad movie it
opened wide and all the wayans brothers
have been in
it uh and then trump like this was i
mean the trump roast this one i got in
so much trouble for anthony jasmine is
here do you guys know anthony comedian
yeah he was this was his first roast was
the trump roast i feel like if i saw a
picture of him i know but i probably
just yeah you know he's like just why
wait who who did the trump bro said
bombed um
ooh
oh the situation yeah yeah yeah didn't
you say cover up that that's this
situation yeah
yeah yeah that exactly anthony justin
look is here this is his first time on
the road you did the trump rules holy
shit you know nothing about me yes
everything and then i've remembered the
jokes it's funny watching you realize
who i am
two bro girls what
he was like i'm just realizing that i'm
not talking to joan rivers
i just realized how much
how famous you actually are
i said uh this is the first time
someone's lost their virginity around
donald trump without him having to
promise some american citizenship
i remember the the dude the trump rush
was so funny it was great dude that was
a rough one dude because it was also he
didn't laugh at any of them he didn't
really laugh at any of them yeah which
is weird why do you sign up to do that
if you're not going to well he's like
famously implemented he get paid for it
he didn't care about any of the
like he's sort of like but he knew
exactly what he was doing like he knows
like if i'm a punching bag this is gonna
make it look like all the hollywood
elites are just being mean to me and
like he knew exactly what he was doing
right like at that time the whole joke
was you're running for president this is
a publicity stunt no you're not
like he knew he became the resident he
knew exactly what he was doing like he
knew that's all he was roasts make you
like people so much when they get
roasted that he knew exactly what he was
doing um but um okay i love you we have
to stop i know can we do it
don't you do that
yes i've always wanted to do that
i always wanted to do that i think i
just fell in love
it's so wild because it's like it's
forgotten it's such a bigger thing now
like i'll be walking on the street
you're like i'm like what the fuck i'm
like oh oh you know where else you know
we're from you know that tick tock sound
that's going viral right now with icarly
it's like oh that was you you asked her
what your favorite customer was yep
yeah i you created the biggest meme like
it was it's awesome on tick tock why is
that so big just because she said fuck
my dad
what's your favorite curse word probably
fuck
the second one that comes in the
maniacal one is me uh why is it going
help me understand tic toc why
is it dude did you hear it
one person starts it makes it funny but
it's just kind of like the sound is so
great i feel like it just it just the
most vital thing of tick tock about me
was like i'm not a boxer i'm not a
fighter i never claimed to be a fighter
did you hear that one yeah well yes
because then we watched the window i
never claimed
yeah yeah like what's the common
denominator and the ones that go viral
is there like a science to it i mean the
only thing i think we predicted that
would go out and actually was like dance
trends and stuff back like when tech
talk first started like we'd start like
trends or stuff like that i'm sweating
yeah
out of here i love you guys don't write
elephants i
you know what unfollow them on social
media
i love you guys
[Music]
four four four five
[Music]
you